all right
loyalty hi welcome welcome back
thank you for having me back so what's
been going on since
uh almost two weeks that you were here
last
um i've started to change the way that
i'm
doing things i've started
ever since i saw you last like i started
thinking a lot more about my future and
about
what i should be doing now to get that
far you know
um and i've changed like
my living situations i'm i moved to a
different area
but you're still living on the street
yeah i'm still on the street i'm still
in the tent
but i just move locations i'm not on
skid row anymore
um like in the 30s now um i just wanted
to move myself a little bit i still have
my addiction
so i just wanted to move myself a little
bit farther away from
like the main piece so i'm not in so
much drama and so much
unnecessary stuff you know good idea
[Music]
good thinking so i don't know if you've
seen your video or seen the comments on
your video but there's been
quite a bit of response to your your
story
a lot of people want to help you out a
lot a lot of people offered their homes
to you they offer jobs they offer
you know there's some people that have
sent money which
which is tricky because sending money to
a fentanyl addict is
is not always the best idea well just
know that
my my fentanyl addiction um
i haven't taken care of for the most
part
how's that like
i have a really good connection right
now so
i get it for like low prices yeah but so
all of my money
i don't i mean i don't really have any
money right now um
you're about to but i'm hungry you know
yeah
i'll ration out money to you slowly so
you don't do anything crazy
but um but because you have a drug
addiction you're gonna do things to get
that money that you need
regardless right yeah so giving it to
you makes your life a little bit safer
yeah until you go into a rehab or go on
suboxone or something like that
yeah um so
i mean your talk last time you you you
know you you
told us that you you've done all the
things you needed to do to get your life
together
you were addicted to heroin once and you
got off it and you kind of
had a job in a car and a boy for 11
years yeah 11 years so
you did you did this once before are you
in
are you in the mindset to do it again
right now um
honestly if i could get off the street
and
i can basically get the opportunity
to change my life because right now i'm
just waiting for that opportunity you
know
i think you've got a lot of
opportunities that you don't
realize yet
one of them is with monica at the
patrick katie foundation who's in uh
in nashville of all places where you're
from oh wow
she's currently she's recently moved to
nashville so
that would be one of the best options
for you i would think if you're if
you're willing to go to nashville
and that could be a great thing i'll put
you on the phone with her as soon as
we're done here
um but regardless there's all kinds of
people that want to support you and help
you
get your life together and all that so
i'll steer you in in the right direction
with all these people that want to help
and and we'll we'll get you
some support but i don't want to support
you just like hanging out in the street
and doing fountains yeah
that's not what we're talking about so
so
if you're on board with with getting
your life together i think we can
probably do some things with with my
my viewers and uh and uh
in the gofundme campaign that's kind of
helping you out and also also all the
people in the comments that have been
emailing me as well and just how do i
help loyalty how do i help her how do i
help her
so we can do all that stuff for you
definitely we should be really nice
right
i mean you've been using you've been
smoking fentanyl smoking or injecting
yeah i smoked smoking how long
um i go through about a hundred dollars
a day
um
i'm trying to slowly but surely
eventually stop on my own like without
like a rehab or
anything because honestly it's in your
mind you know
an addiction is an addiction in your
mind
and it's it's basically like a habit
once you do it for so
long you do get addicted to it not not
only
emotionally and mentally but physically
too with fentanyl it's a physical
addiction
my body physically craves it i go
through these withdrawal stages
where i will get the shake so
um my bowels will
move without me moving them um
i will throw up um i cry because my
bones hurt so bad
i can't even get up out of bed whenever
i don't have it you know
but it's only like at six hours that's
whenever it starts
because that's six hours that it's
already processed through your body
at 12 hours that's whenever the
withdrawal actually
is in full motion and
with fentanyl it attacks your central
nervous system
and certain neurotransmitters in your
head
and it's tied to your dopamine
and what it does is like this is like
your dopamine regularly
this is it with veno it just puts puts a
mask on it you know
and it completely replaces them
certain ones anyway so whenever you
don't have that it's like my body's
missing
missing certain things you know like
happiness
and my physical body
you know so it's like it's a lot harder
than people think to
to stop you can't just stop like that
you have to
do it slowly you have to slowly
put yourself off of it you know
and when you quit heroin which is
similar to fentanyl how did you do that
um i stopped basically because i had the
opportunity to stop
i had a lot of things going for me and
my job had drug tested me
every week we would have to do a drug
test
and if you had anything in your system
they would fire you
and i didn't want to lose my job you
know i didn't want to lose my house my
my boyfriend my my dog my cars i didn't
want to lose my that
you know i worked my ass off to get that
[ __ ]
but it got taken away anyway so that's
why i started doing it again
but when you when you quit you did a
cold turkey or you did it with suboxone
or something like that
um i did it with um i can't think of the
name right now
methadone yep methadone i use method
that got me off of it and then i stopped
using methadone after a couple of weeks
you know
so i never went back you know after
the third time that i had went i didn't
go back
so i got off of that as well because
methadone you can actually get addicted
too too
yeah what would you like to do with your
life if you got everything
straightened out i want my happiness
back
um sadly i don't think i could get my
relationship back i don't think i could
get my dog back i don't think i can get
my my cars or my house back but i sure
as hell can get something
not to replace it but better than that
you know you're very young yet so you'll
have other cars and houses and dogs
right i'll bet you you'll have other
relationships too
but your your health mental health
physical health all that stuff that
you're
lacking right now is what's most
important because once you get that then
all the other stuff
will fall into place but you won't have
any of the other things
you can maybe get a dog but that's about
it and you'll have nothing else and
you'll be
stuck in this life like a lot of people
you see here that are down here for
decades
yeah and you're you're new here you've
been only down here how long
um i've been here in l.a well and on
skid row
on skid row you're brand new about nine
months
right when cover 19 happened when you
lost your job that's when
you lost your house and everything else
yeah
well i'm sure myself and a lot of
viewers would love to see you
kind of make some make some moves to get
your life
straight um
so i'll set you up with some people that
have said they want to help you and
we'll see how serious they are
um i'll put you on the phone with monica
and we'll see how
how you guys get along and uh hopefully
we get you uh
some support to get you out of this
this hell hole what do you think of skid
row um
it's treacherous right definitely
definitely one of the worst places you
could be yeah
yeah it's horrible and for a young girl
a young white girl especially i think
it's
really dangerous i'm sure you've seen
some of that stuff already
yeah it sounds like
so so what are you doing now to to get
money for fentanyl
and food and whatever else um
well on the streets especially on skid
row it's a lot easier to get drugs
than food or shelter or
any of that um
[Music]
i don't really uh i'm not i'm not
um
i i don't really want to talk about that
you know like this
i won't make you you know it's kind of
sad it's kind of
expressing very personal yeah i
understand
i won't cry hopefully this will be a
chapter in your life that just
kind of you put behind you and you move
on
hopefully and hopefully you never come
back to a situation like this ever again
definitely not because even with kovid
you'd still probably do some things to
get
your life straight and get even get in
get a job
you can do a lot of great things despite
all these obstacles that we have
all right john i wish you the best of
luck here and we'll
see what we can do to help you out thank
you all right